JOINING US TODAY.
OUR IT APPEARS THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT SO -- AND LET'S
TAKE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THERE.
REALLY -- PRESIDENT OF JONES
[inaudible]
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
DODD.
GALGIANI.
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL PRESENT MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
NOW THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
COURT ON THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES -- IN ADDITION
TO TECHNICAL CLEAN UP.
THE RULES CHANGES INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COPIES OF AMENDMENTS
TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
HELLO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO.
I REALLY AYE JONES JONES I
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BEATS I BRIDGES.
OR JUST AYE DODD.
GALGIANI.
GLAZER.
HUESO.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I'D MORE LOCK MORE LIKE
I PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
THANK YOU SO MOTION PASSES SAU
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
FROM -- CENTER BRADFORD SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR IS HE PRESENT.
HELLO MISTER BRADFORD
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK MEDICARE MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT.
SB FIVE THREE FOUR WANT TO THANK
TO CHEER ON THE COMEDIAN'S SELF
WORKED -- HELPING THIS MAJOR
MOVE FOR I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK.
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OUTLINED IN THE BILL'S ANALYSIS
IN FACT WE HAVE ALREADY MADE A
LOT OF PROGRESS ON THOSE ISSUES --
WITH -- DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE
STARTED AND WE'LL BE ONGOING AS
THIS POLICY MOVES FORWARD.
SB. FIVE THREE FOUR HAS THREE
COMPONENTS FIRST WRIST OBVIOUS
INSURANCE REQUIRED DIVERSITY
SURVEYS STOPS IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHICH SUNSET
ON JANUARY ONE OF THIS YEAR THE
SURVEY REQUIRED EACH INSURANCE
COMPANY IT DOES AT LEAST A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
IN CALIFORNIA PREMIUMS TO REPORT
THE EFFORTS TO PROCURE GOODS AND
SERVICES FROM DIVERSE.
BUSINESSES SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY.
INSURANCE COMPANIES WERE
REQUIRED TO REPORT ON THEIR
PROCUREMENT FROM MINORITY.
WOMEN OWNED AND DISABLED
VETERANS ALL BUSINESSES THE
TRANSPARENCY TREAT THROUGH THE
SURVEY HAS HELPED HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSE
CONTRACTING WITH IN THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THE GREAT
SUCCESS WITH THE UTILITIES FOR
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS WITH
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY IN WERE STAN
AND NOW WITH SB.
ONE THAT ALSO HAS A SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY COMPONENTS SO THIS IS
NOTHING NEW AND IT MOVES IN THE
DIRECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT IT.
AS A RESULT OF CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE RETIREMENT WITH
DIVERSE ON BUSINESSES IT ROLLS
93% OVER THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD
FROM NINE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE TO ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SB
FIVE BEFORE INSURERS THAT THIS
DATA CAMP I CAN'T CONTINUE TO BE
COLLECTED.
INCLUDES DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
CATEGORIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED SUCH AS
LGBT OWNED AND VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES -- SECOND -- FIVE
THREE FOUR CODIFIES THE
GOVERNING BOARD DIVERSITY SERVER
THE SURVEY DESIGNED TO IMPROVE
DIVERSITY AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT AN INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
THE SURVEY IS ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARILY BY AND VOLUNTARY.
AND GIVES EACH BOARD MEMBER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELF REPORTER
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
INSURERS ACROSS THE STATE
REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THAT NEARLY 80% OF
INSURANCE COMPANIES GOVERNING
BOARD SEATS WERE HELD BY MEN.
AND ONLY 12% OF THE SEATS WERE
HELD BY PEOPLE OF COLOR.
OF THE NEARLY TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED BOARD SEATS ONLY
FOURTEEN MEMBERS SELF.
IDENTIFIED AS LGBT. 13% REPORTED
ZERO WOMEN AND 35% REPORTED ZERO
PERSONS OF COLOR ON THE
GOVERNING BOARD.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE
DIVERSITY IS INTRINSICALLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE INDUSTRY AND
OUR STATE AS A WHOLE AS STATED.
ITS BENEFIT ALL THE OTHER
INDUSTRIES -- SEVEN S. ACCEPTED.
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT BOARDS ARE BETTER
EQUIPPED TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AND CARRY OUT.
THE FIDUCIARY DUTIES WHEN THEY
HAVE A DIVERSE MIX OF BOARD
MEMBERS FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS AND EXPERIENCES IT
IS VITAL THAT WE CONTINUE TO
COLLECT.
THIS DATA IN ORDER TO FIND THE
BEST APPROACH IS TO EVALUATE AN
INCREASE DIVERSITY IN INSURANCE
MARKETS.
LASTLY FIVE THREE FOUR CODIFIES
INSURANCE DIVERSITY TASK FORCE
THE TASK FORCE IS COMPRISED OF
FIFTEEN MEN MEMBERS APPOINTED BY
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER WHO
ARE PRESENT INSURANCE COMPANIES.
X. WRITTEN SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
AND GOVERNING BOARDS DIVERSITY
AND AND DIVERSE BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES TASK FORCE ADVISES
AND PROVIDES RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE APARTMENT OF INSURANCE ON
HOW THEY CAN BEST MEET THEIR
DIVERSITY GOALS.
SB FIVE THREE FOR INSURERS A
MEANINGFUL DATA CONTINUES TO BE
COLLECTED AND BILLS UPON
PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE INDUSTRY IS
INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY AS MICHAEL
MARTINEZ SENIOR DIRT SENIOR DOOR --
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND LINDA.
ROCKETS TO GO ALLAH.
I'M I SAID I WAS GOING TO GET
THE RIGHT IN A MESS THAT AT
PRESENT NCO LEADERSHIP EDUCATION
FOR THE ASIAN PACIFIC --
INCORPORATED I RESPECT LAST
REVIVAL.
MISTER MARTINEZ RED HOT MAYBE
AFTERNOON TO REVIEW AND MEMBERS
AND ADVISED HER JONES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HER MICHAEL MARTINEZ SENIOR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER.
OF THE DEPARTMENT INSURANCE HERE
FOR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA.
AND WE ARE PROBABLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE AS A SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE AND WANT TO THANK.
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR HIS
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THE SIDE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE HERE FOR
OUR STATE.
I ABSOLUTELY JUST TO PROJECT THE
THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS AND JUST
THREW OUT OF THEM BRIEFLY SO WE
CAN ALLOW OUR OUT OF TOWN --
WITNESSES TO TO HAVE A BIT MORE
TIME IS THAT THE COMMISSION DOES
BELIEVE ENCOURAGING PROCUREMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STATE'S
SMALL BUSINESSES AND GOVERNING
BOARD OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
PEOPLE THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO
GREAT ECONOMIC.
BENEFITS FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND THE BILL DOES ALLOW AND WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
LEVERAGE THIS RAPID GROWTH.
OF THE INSURANCE SECTORS ROLE IN
CONTRIBUTING TO VIBRANT LOCAL
ECONOMIES.
IDENTICAL TO WHAT.
MISTER BRADFORD HAD STATED OF
THE COMMITMENT AND MOVING
FORWARD -- SHOULD AND AS
HOPEFULLY THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
TO THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
COMMISSIONER WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE -- REMAINING
ISSUES WITH THE BILL AND WHAT
THE AUTHOR AND WITH THE OFFERING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF -- TWO
REGISTERS THE LAST REMAINING
ISSUES WITH THE BILL.
AND AGAIN WORKING WITH INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES IS THE BILL CONTINUES
MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO THAT BEING SAID WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- AND REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
I WAS THE FIRST WITNESS.
LOW CHAIR RUBIO IN OF VICE CHAIR
JONES -- MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LINDA COULD YOU GO AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO FELIPE
LEADERSHIP EDUCATION FOR ASIAN
PACIFICS.
AND I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR FOR DIVERSITY WHICH
IS A COALITION OF FOR LEADERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS MADE UP OF
CATALYST A WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION.
HE'LL SEE OR THE EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WHICH IS
FOCUSED ON AFRICAN AMERICAN
EXECUTIVES HISPANIC ASSOCIATION
CORPORATE RESPONSIBILITY.
WHICH IS FOCUSED ON INCREASING
CORPORATE ARE REPRESENTATION OF
LATINOS AND HISPANICS ON OF IN
COMPANIES AND LEAP WHICH IS MY
ORGANIZATION WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
A CAPPING LEADERSHIP FROM WITHIN
THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC ON THE
COMMUNITIES I AM ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE OF THE INSURANCE
DIVERSITY TASK FORCE.
AT THE CALIFORNIA DIVERT --
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AS WELL --
TO AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE ALL
OF YOU TODAY -- I'M HERE ON BOTH
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR POOR
DIVERSITY AND LEAD TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR
OF FOR VARIOUS REASONS ON
SPECIFICALLY ONE OF OUR PIECES --
OR THE ONE OF OUR PIECES OF THE
ALLIANCE FOR POOR DIVERSITY IS A
MULTI YEAR STUDY THAT WE DO
CONDUCT AT CALLED MISSING PIECES
IT IS OUR LATEST REPORT WAS
RELEASED JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
WHICH LOOKS AT THE DIVERSITY OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES ON FORTUNE
FIVE HUNDRED CORPORATE BOARDS
HAND IN THE OUT WE DO IDENTIFY.
CERTAIN NUMBERS IN WHICH WE DO
SEE THAT AMONG FORTUNE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES -- THERE IS STILL A
LACK OF DIVERSITY ON THESE
CORPORATE BOARDS OF FOR EXAMPLE
MEN STILL OCCUPY 75% OF FORTUNE
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
POINT 5% OF FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES.
IN TERMS OF LOOKING OUT OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR WERE SEEN DAD --
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
OCCUPY ONLY THREE POINT 8% OF
FORTUNE ONE HUNDRED COMPANY
BOARD SEATS -- FORTINOS OCCUPY
ONLY FOUR POINT 4% AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS OCCUPY ONLY JUST A
LITTLE OVER 11% RESPECTIVELY ON
FORTUNE ONE HUNDRED OUR BOARDS.
THE NUMBERS ARE NOT THAT MUCH
BETTER FOR FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
I DO ALSO WANT T SAVE -- JUST
ONE NOTE IS THAT AS I LOOK OUT
WHO ARE THE NEW BOARD MEMBERS
COMING ON TO THESE FORTUNE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTUNE.
FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY BOARDS NEW
SEATS ARE NOT NECESSARILY GOING
TO WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN LARGE
NUMBERS WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT MORE THAN HALF OF NEW BOARD
MEMBERS THAT CONTINUE TO BE
ADDED.
CONTINUE TO BE WHITE MEN OF WHAT
WE ARE SEEING THOUGH IS THAT
THERE IS SOME PROGRESS BUT WHAT
I DO BELIEVE IS OUT WHAT GETS
MEASURED GETS DONE.
AND SO -- WHAT WE ARE EEING
THROUGH OUR REPORT IS THAT?
WE'RE SEEING COMPANIES LIKE
PRUDENTIAL FINANCIAL HAVE THE
BROADEST DIVERSITY MEANING THAT
THEY HAVE WOMEN.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO AND
ASIANS ON THEIR BOARDS -- WHAT
WE'RE ALSO SEEING IS THAT
RESEARCH DONE BY COMPANIES LIKE
MACKENZIE IS SHOWING THAT THE
FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE?
OF INSURANCE COMPANIES AND OTHER
LARGE COMPANIES.
DO REFLECT GREATER FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE WHEN YOU HAVE A MORE
DIVERSE BOARD AND IN FACT WHEN A
BOARD IS MADE UP OF ETHNIC
DIVERSITY WERE SEEN ACTUALLY OF
43%.
DIFFERENCE áWEEN
DIVERSE AND THE LEAST DIVERSE
COMPANIES IN TERMS OF THEIR
PERFORMANCE AND SO.
AS A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN -- I
WOULD.
EXPECT THAT ANYBODY WHO'S GONNA
BE DOING BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE LOOKING TO
ACHIEVE THE BEST KIND OF
PERFORMANCE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO FOR THIS PURPOSE I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT -- AS A MEMBER
OF THE INSURANCE DIVERSITY TASK
FORCE AS WELL.
TOO I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE IS
OF IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S ALSO OF
IMPORTANCE -- TO TO THOSE WHO --
WORK AND ALSO BENEFIT FROM THESE
COMPANIES DOING BUSINESS HERE
AND SO I DO WANT TO SAY THAT --
AS AN ADVOCATE I DO WANT TO IN
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE
CONSIDER.
ALL IN RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU LINDA.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO THE I CHAIR VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY.
MY NAME IS JAY GREENE I'M THE
PRINCIPLE OF THE GREEN LAW FIRM
THE GREEN LAW FIRMS A CERTIFIED
LGBT BUSINESS ENTERPRISE.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE GOLDEN GATE
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IS THE
WORLD'S OLDEST L. G. B. T.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
IT'S LOCATED IN SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE'S DIVERSITY TASK FORCE.
I'M LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW IN
CALIFORNIA FLORIDA AND
SURPRISINGLY ENOUGH ALABAMA.
I LIKE MANY OF YOUR ANCESTORS
CAME TO CALIFORNIA AND HOPES --
FOR GREATER OPPORTUNITY. FOR
GENERATION AFTER GENERATION
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A STATE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FREE TO BE THEMSELVES.
AND THEY SUCCEED BECAUSE OF THAT
DIVERSITY.
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
IT'S INITIATIVE REPORTING
STARTED IN TWENTY TWELVE L. G.
B. T. OWN DIVERSE SPENDING
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED FROM A
HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THE NINE POINT NINE MILLION
THIS IS AN INCREASE OF 95% JUST
FROM THE FACT THAT WE'RE
TRACKING RESULTS.
THIS IS HAD AN IMPACT OF TWENTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NATIONAL DIVERSE LGBT SPAN WHICH
IS AN INCEASE OF THREE TIMES
SINCE REPORTING STARTED IN.
TWENTY TWELVE THE INFORMATION
GATHERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
THROUGH THE INITIATIVE HAS
ALLOWED OUR CHAMBER TO PINPOINT
AND RECOGNIZE THE COMPANIES WITH
SIGNIFICANT LGBT SPAN.
AND TARGET OTHER COMPANIES WHERE
THERE LGBT SPAN CAN BE INCREASED.
THE CATEGORY LEVEL OF DETAIL IN
REPORT. FOR SPANNED ALLOWS US AS
A CHAMBER TO PINPOINT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR MEMBERS.
AND MAKE INTRODUCTIONS TO
CORPORATE PROCUREMENT
PROFESSIONALS AT THOSE COMPANIES --
WE CAN'T OFFER THIS LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO OUR CHAMBER MEMBERS --
WITH AL THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE REAP
PROVIDING THE DEPARTMENT.
THROUGH THE INSURANCE DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE. THREE THE WORK OF
THE INSURANCE DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE AND OTHER SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY INITIATIVES Mà LAW
FIRM HAS HAD MEETINGS WITH SOME
OF THE LARGEST FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES IN THE COUNTRY.
THESE ARE MEETINGS THAT WOULD
NEVER BEEN A POSSIBILITY FOR MY
LAW FIRM IN ALABAMA.
THE CALIFORNIA AND THE SENATORS
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY HAS
ALLOWED ME TO REACH HIGHER AND
PURSUE YOU I'D FAR GREATER.
THAN I COULD HAVE IMAGINED.
I LOOK FORWARD -- TO MY FURTHER
WORK ON THE INSURANCE DIVERSITY
TASKFORCE AND I IN THE JEEP.
BE A ENCOURAGE -- THE COMMITTEE --
TO GIVE AN AYE VOTE FOR SB. FIVE
FIVE THREE FOUR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE OPPORTUNITIES IT SAYS
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE
TO INVITE ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANTHONY GLOSSY
WITH THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI PENNY BORDER WALL ONBEHALF
OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
BUT THIS PLAN I'LL ASK ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY MCCUE
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
CONCERNS COMPANIES.
I WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
HOWEVER WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS BERRY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AS WELL AS A
SPONSOR AND WE'RE VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD TODAY SO THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS CAN'T CONTINUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEVEN TAYLOR WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE.
AND COLD BILL I LAUDABLE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND THE COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU.
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM OUR MEMBERS [inaudible]
MISTER BURGESS.
THANK YOU SURE WOMAN JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE SERVICE
SYSTEM WORKS I DON'T KNOW TO
WHOM I SHOULD ADDRESS THE
QUESTION -- IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS
ALSO A BOARD MEMBER.
IS IT THAT BOARD MEMBERS --
PROVOCATIVE -- TO REVEALED THEIR
IDENTIFICATION FOR EXAMPLE IF
THERE MEMBER OF ON THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
IS IT UPON THEM TO SELF TO CLEAR
OR IS IT UPON.
THE EMPLOYER TO DECLARE ON THEIR
BEHALF.
HOW DOES WHERE IS THE RIGHT OF
DECLARATION IDENTIFICATION LIVE
IT'S VOLUNTARILY IT'S A
VOLUNTARY -- INFORMATION AND
IT'S UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL THE
COMPANY CAN'T TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES.
TO AS ON BY YEAH YEAH SO IT'S UP
TO THE INDIVIDUAL.
OKAY SO THAT INDIVIDUAL CLIENTS
YES IT'S FINE.
THANK YOU KNOW ISSUE THERE THAT.
ANYBODY ELSE MISTER BLASIER --
CENTER BRADFORD AYE IF I MISS
THIS IN YOUR OPENING MS MY
APOLOGIES -- THAT THAT COULD YOU
AYE AYE.
ELABORATE MAYBE IN YOUR CLOTHES
ON NOT WHAT THE ISSUES ARE THAT
ARE STILL THAT DIFFERENT
DIFFERING WITH THE INDUSTRY SO
WE CAN JUST BE AWARE OF THOSE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK MY WITNESSES FOR
COMING FORTH AS WELL ALYSSA.
MISS MARTINEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE OUT WHAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS IS THAT.
BY PROVIDING THIS INFORMATION IT
PROVIDES FOR A GREATER GROWTH OF
DIVERSE BUSINESSES TO DO WORK
WITH INSURANCE AGENCIES AS WE'VE
SEEN FOR THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
WHERE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED SERVE
OUR SUPPLIER DIVERSITY IN A
UTILITY SPACE UNDER GENERAL
ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX WE HAVE NOW
WE'RE WILL EXCEED TEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF SPEND THIS YEAR WITH
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES AND DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS AS WE WANT TO ACHIEVE
THAT SAME GOAL?
AND THIS INSURANCE SPACE -- IT
IS ONE OF THE LAST BASTIONS OF
MALE DOMINATED INDUSTRY AND WE
FEEL AGAIN IF.
YOU'RE CONTRACTORS IN.
THE TO PROCURE WHAT LOOKS LIKE
CALIFORNIA THE SAME CUSTOMER
BASE THAT YOU REPRESENT YOU
SHOULD BE WANTED TO DO BUSINESS
WITH THEM.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WE ALSO PUT DIVERSE TO
LET AND LANGUAGE -- TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN SB. ONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WOMEN OWN A MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES IN OUR DISABLED
VETERAN TOP OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BUSINESS IN THAT SPACE AS WELL
SO THIS IS JUST FOLLOWING A
TRADITION THAT WE HAVE STARTED.
AND WE TRULY BELIEVE IN BEING IN
THE MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THE
NATION THAT.
ARE CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES
ARE ENTREPRENEUR Là OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD BE REFLECTIVE OF THAT
GREAT DIVERSITY AND THAT'S THE
SOLE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL -- AND
MAKING SURE THAT -- YOU'RE
YOU'RE WHO YOU DO BUSINESS WITH
IS JUST AS DIVERSITY YOUR
CUSTOMER BASE ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR DR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON A LOT
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
EXPRESSED AS A PERTAINS TO WHAT
MISTER BURGESS.
ALSO EXPRESS AND HE'S VERY
COMMITTED TO FOCUSING ON THE
RESPECT FOR INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
WILL CONTAIN AGO -- ON THIS
ISSUE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR TESTIMONY
I I DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR.
HOLLY MITCHELL -- CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THANK YOU THIS IS DOUBLE
REFER TO JUDICIARY.
YES REFER TO GESTURE.
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO IT'S A DO PASS AND REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RUBIO.
HI THE BILL I JONES [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS PORTIS
[inaudible]
DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER LATER I
HUESO.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA PUT THE BILL
ON CALL MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBER
GIL -- NEXT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
SB FIVE FORTY BY JONES.
MISTER JONES
.
DO I HAVE.
LIKE
.
SEVEN MISTER JONES YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU REDDING ITEM
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES -- I THINK THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL ON AN INTERESTING
TOPIC -- SO WE'LL SEE HOW IT
WORKS OUT -- IT'S A NEW IT'S A
NEW TOPIC TO ME.
AND IT'S BEEN A FIND -- LEARNING
EXPERIENCE A SPLIT DOLLAR LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY ALLOWS THE COST
AND BENEFIT OF A PERMANENT LIFE
INSURANCE POLICY TO BE SHARED.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY ALLOWS
NONPROFITS TO OFFER THESE UNIQUE
POLICIES TO THEIR OFFICERS AS AN
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT.
THAT ENDS UP BEING COST NEUTRAL
TO THE NONPROFIT.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THIS
ARRANGEMENT TO HOLD BOTH THE
CASH SURRENDER VALUE AND THE
DEATH BENEFIT AS SECURITY.
HOWEVER THIS REQUIREMENT TAKES
AWAY THE BENEFIT TO THE OFFICER
SINCE THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
UTILIZE ANY OF THE CASH VALUE OF
THE POLICY SINCE IT IS.
REQUIRED TO BE HELD AS SECURITY
FOR THE ARRANGEMENT.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY SLIGHTLY
ADJUSTS THE VALUE THAT IS
REQUIRED TO BE HELD A SECURITY.
ON A SPLIT DOLLAR LIFE INSURANCE
POLICY UNDER A LOAN REGIME. TO
EITHER THE DEATH BENEFIT OR THE
CASH SURRENDER VALUE OR BOTH.
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPTED BOTH OF THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
BILL THESE AMENDMENTS WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THE CONTRACT BETWEEN
THE NONPROFIT AND THE OFFICER.
OR THE COLLATERAL ASSIGNMENT
AGREEMENT IS TRULY COST NEUTRAL
FOR THE NONPROFIT.
THIS BILL GIVES NON PROFITS IN
CALIFORNIA RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION TOOL TO COMPETE IN THE
EMPLOYEE IN THE EMPLOYMENT
MARKET.
I GET RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO INTEREST ANYBODY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY I WILL OPEN IT UP -- FOR
MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS.
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
HERE -- AFTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN WHEN THE AGREEMENT HAPPENED
BETWEEN THE TWO ENTITIES IS
THERE A SET AMOUNT SIXTY FORTY
FIFTY FIFTY ANYTHING IN THE
FUTURE OR THAT SOMETHING THAT
THEY CAN WORK ON MYSELF WE'RE
NOT MANDATED ANYTHING BUT OUR
STANDING AS THEY CAN?
WHAT WELL IT'S BASED ON THE
VALUE OF THE LIFE OF THE POLICY
DOES THE POLICY MATURES AND?
THE LIMIT THAT THEY CAN TAKE HIS
ARE REGULATED SO THAT THE
OFFICER CAN'T TAKE MORE THAN THE
VALUE OF THE POLICY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO WORK IT OUT
THEMSELVES CORRECT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
CENTER MITCHELL DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'M GONNA
LAY OFF THE BILL TODAY OKAY
HAVING SPENT MOST OF MY CAREER
IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR --
UNFAMILIAR WITH THIS PRODUCT --
AYE AYE AYE.
DO NOT SUPPORT THE ARGUMENT THAT
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
PARTICULARLY TODAY'S ECONOMY IS
HAVING TROUBLE ATTRACTING TOP
TALENT.
OF THE NONPROFIT TO DOING WELL
COMPARED TO PRIVATE SECTOR AND
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT MATTER -- I
KNOW IT'S BEEN DOUBLE REFERRED
TO I'M GONNA GET THE SPECIFICS
OF MY QUESTIONS TO YOU AS WELL
AS THE CONSULTANT IN THE OTHER
COMMITTEE -- I JUST THINK IT
COULD I I JUST HAVE SOME RATHER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I'M JUST
GONNA LAY OFF -- AND IF THE
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED AND IT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO ME THAT IT'S A
SOLUTION THAT'S LOOKING FOR
PROBLEM NOT BE HAPPEN AWAY IN
LATER BUT I'LL BE LAYING OFF
TODAY MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR
COMING BEFORE US TODAY SO -- I
DO HAVE -- GONNA BUT IF I CAN
ADDRESS MS MISSILES JUST REAL
QUICK -- MY UNDERSTANDING AND
THIS IS AN AND WE'LL GET ALL
THAT STUFF FOR TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
MOST THE TIME THIS PARTY'S USED
FOR A HOSPITAL EXECUTIVES.
RIGHT OKAY GOOD I THANK YOU
THAT'S OR JUST LAST [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY TAX.
BUT ALSO ON THE NONPROFIT IN THE
GREAT STUFF WE WILL GET THOSE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO DO YOU WANT TO
CLOSER WHICH IT THAT'S MY CHOICE
[inaudible]
HI.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY BOARD AS A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
DO PASS AS AMENDED AND ROOF RE
REFER TO BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO. FIVE RUBIO AYE JONES
JONES I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BEATS BRIDGES.
WHICH IS AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HUESO MITCHELL MORE
LOCK.
MOORLACH I PORTANTINO. TWENTY
NINE I ROTH.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE IN A PLACE
THE BELL ON HONG KONG TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OUR COLLEAGUES AT
OPPORTUNITY WILL [inaudible]
THE MYSTERON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO VOTE ON THIS
ITEM OR A PASS [inaudible] FORTY
NINE IT'S SB FIVE FORTY JONES
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS.
THE CURRENT VOTERS NINETY ZERO
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO A AND RE REFER TO YOU SHE
BANKING AND FINANCE SOCIAL
INSTITUTION COMMITTEE.
ROTH AYE.
SO I WILL PUT THAT ON CALL TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE UP AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OR ANYBODY.
MOVE IT.
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR GLAZER [inaudible]
AT LEAST.
CALL THE ROLL BUT IT
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
BY.
I JONES.
HI JONES I ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA IBEATS.
BEATS I BRIDGES.
WE'RE JUST AYE DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
HUESO [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK.
MOORLACH AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
HI.
THANK YOU SO THAT IS A MOTION TO
PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN UP THE CALL
ON SB. FIVE THIRTY FOUR BRAD.
FOR SORRY WE'RE OPENING THE CALL
FOR SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR BRADFORD.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IT IS.
SEVEN ZERO SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR
DO PASS AND WE REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BEATS
[inaudible]
FAITH [inaudible] FOR JESS
HUESO.
MORE LOCK.
LOS [inaudible]
I NOW I WILL OPEN UP THE THE
FINAL OF THE STATE.
THE FINAL VOTE ON SB FIVE THIRTY
FOUR IS EIGHT TWO ZERO THE VOTE
IS OUT.
FINAL VOTE.
CALL.
NOW.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE ON CALL
DO YOU WANNA LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
HUESO WAS PRESENT.
YOU CAN ANSWER THE PHONE CLOSED.
SO.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE ON CALL.
FOR SENATE RACE.
OKAY AT THIS POINT WAY
UNDERSTAND SENATOR HUESO IS UP
PRESENTING AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
SO WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE DOOR
OPEN TO GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE.
SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE CALL ON
SB FIVE FORTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE CURRENT VOTERS TEND TO ZERO
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE BATES.
I DID BATES AYE[inaudible]
THANK.
THE CRRENT LOTUS ELEVEN ZERO WE
WILL BE LEAVING IT OPEN FOR
SENATOR WHISTLE TO MAKE IT BACK
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
SO AT THIS POINT IF I CAN ASK
THE SERGEANTS TO SEE WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHERE MISTER HUESO IS
AND LET HIM KNOW THAT WE'RE
READY FOR HIM [inaudible]
I THOUGHT.
INTERESTED IN CLOSE SO WE CAN
MAKE EVERYTHING OPEN ON A CALL.
FOR OKAY SO AT THIS POINT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A LITTLE RECESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- SENATOR WAS
ALWAYS HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND VOTE AND DOWN.
THEY'LL BE BEGGING HIM NOT THIS
TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER AWAY SO WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE CALL FOR SB FIVE
THIRTY FOUR BRADFORD.
WE HAVE [inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO OTHER OWN
[inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
HUESO I THE BILL PASSES -- NINE
TWO ZERO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE ON SB FIVE FORTY JONES.
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL HUESO [inaudible]
HUESO I DO PAST TWELVE TO ZERO
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO SB
TWO NINE TWO WHICH IS IN CONSENT
CALENDAR UP PLEASE OPEN THE
WRONG.
WAY SO [inaudible]
HUESO AYE.
DO PAST TWELVE TWO ZERO THANK
YOU EVERYONE AT THIS.
WHITE WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU
SO MUCH